d'abord zoom sur la programmation de la
saison prochaine à la Meurice de trappe
quels sont les temps forts de 2023 2024
on en parle avec Francis costard le
directeur de la Meurice et Yoann Nivolet
directeur des affaires culturelles de la
ville de Trappes alors Francis on
parlait tout à l'heure de cette saison
créé ses résister le slogan de cette
saison 2023 2024 à la mairie on va pas
avoir l'occasion de présenter toutes les
dates malheureusement ici mais s'il y a
une idée peut-être directrice une idée
générale sur cette saison ce serait
laquelle à dire on essaie d'avoir
toujours une programmation
pluridisciplinaire et puis plus riche et
rationnel donc on va dire qu'on fait une
programmation pour tous c'est surtout ça
qu'il faut retenir et puis tu peux
regarder tu as créé ces résister tu vois
et si tu la retourne et bien oui
résister c'est créer et donc bon sa
grande phrase de Stéphane Hessel et
c'est vrai qu'on a articulé notre
formation autour de ça voilà et d'avoir
des jeunes talents d'avoir des confirmés
un vrai mélange quoi et donc c'est une
saison qui va démarrer le 10 septembre
prochain avec french twins
un spectacle de magie digital vous le
disiez il y a une grande diversité dans
ce qui est proposé à la Meurice de la
danse du théâtre de l'improvisation
cirque humour mais on va d'ailleurs
débuter en musique et retourner on va
prendre la petite machine à remonter le
temps et retourner dans les années 80
[Musique]
vous êtes dansé sur cette aire Véronique
dans les années 80
groupe for des années 80 qui donc seront
sur la scène de la Merise le 7 octobre à
20h30 il y a des têtes d'affiches qui
viennent à la mairie chaque année oui
oui tout à fait c'est comme tous les ans
en fait Francis nous concote une
programmation très diversifiée avec
quelques têtes d'affiches c'est aussi ce
que souhaite le maire de la ville de
trappes de faire une propose une
programmation qui permettent à la fois
des grands noms comme par exemple Louis
Bertignac ou Stéphanie cher ou
imagination comment on l'a vu mais aussi
des artistes plus confidentiels des
artistes émergents
peuvent être aussi en résidence à la
memorise comme par emprunt sous
l'imprémie d'infos le fil des des
spectacles de théâtre qui s'adressent au
plus grand nombre et qui sont aussi de
très grandes qualités donc imagination
on va danser sur son des années 80-7
octobre yoanni volant
il y a aussi Louis Bertignac qui sera
sur la selle de la Maurice sera le
mercredi 10 janvier 2024 à 20h30 alors
depuis téléphone bien sûr si on est
passé des choses pour lui récemment il a
sorti son dernier album qui s'appelle
dans le film de ma vie
ouais les petites exclusivité de la
saison au niveau rock oui c'est c'est
d'avoir bien sûr Louis qui vient faut
savoir que il appelait Yelle deux jours
après et il va faire une résidence chez
nous il va travailler son show et donc
on va la primeur du show de Pleyel voilà
et puis bah oui il y a d'autres choses
il les insus entre et puis voilà et puis
c'est Cendrillon faut pas l'oublier mais
il se renouvelle
et puis après ces idées là enfin voilà
c'est il y a pas mal de tubes de bien
sûr un autre grand nom de la scène
musicale aussi qui sera présent à la
mairie c'est Stéphan Eicher qui va jouer
lui le samedi 27 janvier à 20h30 et
voilà le chapitre 2 alors il y a pas que
de la musique il y a même de la magie
dans ce spectacle qui sera d'ailleurs
proposé en partenariat avec la scène
nationale le théâtre de 50 ans en
Yvelines la scène nationale ferme voilà
c'est porte mais continue à programmer
et sur cette date on sait aujourd'hui
que Lionel massetta pour mettre en place
voilà un concert
plutôt chanson française et puis voilà
c'était logique de la tournée d'avoir
Stéphane Eicher donc et puis oui imagine
nouvelle qu'est-ce que c'est que la
magie nouvelle c'est pas évident à
expliquer ça se voit surtout
vous avez des automates voilà et puis il
y a toute une vie qui se crée on a un
peu dans le salon de chez Stéphane et
nous invite avec avec des amis à lui et
à découvrir un peu et à avoir
l'installation de ces anciens titres
donc et puis quelques nouvelles voilà
mais beaucoup d'anciennes surtout donc
ça c'est pour la musique on va parler un
peu d'humour les spectateurs sont
également servis avec beaucoup de
propositions et notamment le dimanche 17
décembre à 16h Arthus qui va présenter
son nouveau one man show on sait que de
Trappes sont
issues de nombreux humoristes notamment
grâce à la troupe Déclic Théâtre à la
compagnie théâtrale des clips théâtre
donc de proposer aussi des des
programmations humour aussi important
j'imagine oui c'est très important pour
pour la ville de trappes de poire
continuer cette cette fin de course
poursuite c'était héritage avec
en proposant des des artistes qui font
du one man show qui ont fait rire qui
font rire la France entière et qui et
qui continueront encore et pour nous
c'était vraiment important de pouvoir
avoir progression qui propose à la fois
aussi des ronds puis aussi pareil on est
toujours dans cette dans cet équilibre
entre des grands noms qu'on voulait dire
Artus vous avez peut-être pas en parler
tout à l'heure il y a aussi farine mais
aussi des des humoristes
qui seront qui se produiront le 25
novembre dans le cas de la journée de
lutte contre la violence faite aux
femmes donc voulait aussi mettre à
l'honneur c'est ses humoristes femmes
qui voilà qui parle de sujets importants
et sensibles avec beaucoup d'humour
c'était aussi ça en fait de de pouvoir
traiter le sujet de l'actualité avec
humour et mettre aussi une confiance
aussi dans politique dans ce qui
racontait donc on est sur ces deux
aspects et c'est très important
dont on parlera tout à l'heure aussi met
en valeur justement c'est ces artistes
femmes peut-être un mot sur Artus
Francis costard nouveau one-man-show
pour lui c'est nouveau et c'est un peu
c'est super sympa parce que on a un peu
c'est le tour de chauffe voilà si vous
pour tout vous dire et la préparation au
spectacle il y en a beaucoup parlé et
puis il vient chez nous pour le
justement le tour de chauffe avant la
grande tournée et donc ouais c'est aussi
un peu une exclusivité
et bon on est en tout cas super content
de l'accueillir alors oui c'est un
artiste confirmé comme disait Johan on a
des dollars on a des émergents on a
aussi déjà mis le shlag qui commence à
grimper on a Taïs vauquière aussi enfin
voilà il y a l'humour en gros la marque
de fabrique enfin voilà ce qui se passe
chez nous c'est une place pour le
stand-up l'humour et également la
musique voilà c'est nos deux points
forts donc chaque année vous trouvez ça
ce qui veut pas dire qu'on a pas non
plus aussi du théâtre de la danse de la
danse de la magie mais c'est vrai que la
salle s'y prête on est voilà une des
plus grosses salles au niveau du secteur
parce qu'on configuration debout sur des
concerts jusqu'à 1500 places donc c'est
quand même imposant voilà comme comme
lieu de diffusion et c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on accueille de telle tête de telle
tête d'affiches et on en parlait au
niveau le disait il y aura Fari aussi le
28 février 2024 à 20h30 qui va jouer
aime-moi si tu peux et là aussi c'est un
nouveau spectacle oui oui c'est un
nouveau spectacle il est passé la
semaine dernière à Roland Garros voilà
pour le présenter c'est une tournée
voilà qui qui a démarré et puis c'est
tout nouveau on va regarder un petit
extrait en fait
tu peux pas assumer trop que tu vas à
Dubaï c'est dès qu'il parle de Dubaï en
France les gens sont Dubaï ouais j'aime
pas
c'est déjà aller non mais j'aime pas
j'aime pas parce que je trouve que Dubaï
il y a pas de dame
mais tu es exorciste de quoi tu parles
est-ce que on le rappelle sera le 28
février à 20h30 à la Merise et pour
terminer on va dire un mot de show must
go on les femmes qui vont être de
nouveau à l'honneur à l'occasion de ce
cette nouvelle édition du festival à la
mairie ce qui va se dérouler du 3 au 10
mars donc on le disait le festival qui
met en avant les artistes féminines à
l'occasion d'une date très importante un
lieu chaque année 8 mars c'est la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes
oui tout à fait je j'essayerai
d'ailleurs Francis présenté la
programmation mais c'est un festival
qu'on organise en mars comme vous l'avez
dit dans le cas de de cette journée pour
les femmes mais c'est aussi
l'aboutissement de programmation tout au
long de l'année qu'on propose à Trappes
dans le cadre d'un progression qui
s'appelle pas mal l'honneur et c'est
voilà le choix qu'on fait de pouvoir
toujours mettre
la création
aussi des femmes
en avant pour pour montrer tout le
talent qui est qui est le qui est le
leur
et pour nous c'est important aussi de
véhiculer ce message là dire qu'en fait
quel que soit son genre on peut voilà on
a du talent et on doit pouvoir
l'exprimer et on doit pouvoir être
présenté au plus grand nombre alors que
faut-il retenir de la programmation de
ce festival show must Gohan qui aura
lieu donc je le rappelle du 3 au 10 mars
2024 alors vous avez dit qu'on avait un
mi de côté les jeunes donc les enfants
donc on s'est dit on va faire quelque
chose aussi pour eux donc on commence
avec à il a quelque chose de rêve c'est
un festival qui était repéré par les
Jacques donc c'est un dispositif qu'on a
sur la ville de Trappes qui se sont ce
sont des jeunes ambassadeurs culturels
donc ils viennent avec nous un peu
partout dans différents festivals donc
que ce soit Avignon là on a repéré
celui-là au Grand-Bornand l'année
dernière il y en a d'autres sur vous
tournez les pages vous verrez qu'il y a
d'autres voilà donc ce sont des jeunes
ambassadeurs qui viennent avec nous en
festival on voit on revient la Merise on
peut se procurer ce petit fascicule
et
on voit à peu près une quarantaine de
spectacles par an avec eux et on les
sélectionne et puis ensuite on les
intègre dans notre plaquette et viennent
les défendre aussi ils viennent sur
scène c'est le le jour J en parler et
bah comme on parle d'ambassadeur là ils
vont en parler à leur famille mais à
leurs amis et puis dans les cours voilà
d'école au lycée et bah c'est les
meilleurs ambassadeurs façon sont ils
l'ont vu sont des jeunes donc c'est
intéressant donc il y a ça ensuite je
crois qu'on a l'événement c'est avec la
Comédie Française voilà c'est un
spectacle bon c'est dur c'est un fait
mais c'est voilà c'est sur l'avortement
donc bah c'est une problématique voilà
on peut se passer mieux que ça non plus
voilà
l'autorisation et puis on a également
Nina Lisa sur la vie de
je veux dire Mona Lisa pas du tout
la vie de Nina Simone voilà et de sa
fille
ensuite on a également
dit Lamar voilà un grand actrice des
années 60 on retrouve toute la
programmation sur le site de la Meurice
est donc je le rappelle pour ce festival
qui se déroulera du 3 au 10 mars très
rapidement les tarifs la fourchette de
tarifs à la Merise c'est moins cher
qu'ailleurs
et dans
le plus cher qu'on est c'est ça doit
être Faris voilà qui doit être aux entre
autres 35 euros mais dès que vous avez
en famille nombreuse dès que vous venez
à trois enfin voilà avec vos enfants
tout de suite ça descend à 25 euros
voilà et puis